est ce l'argent qui corrompt ou au
contraire faut-il être corrompu pour
accumuler des milliards
alors qu'un nouveau les successions
c'est l'histoire des membres d'une
famille riche et puissante on sait la
fratrie tous les coups sont permis pour
prendre la tête de l' empire médiatique
fondée par le patriarche login roj c'est
des monstres ce sont des monstres ou est
tout seul personne c'est ce qui est bien
je crois de cette série c'est que
personne n'est sauvé donc effectivement
c'est une série très noir très sombre
mais qui est porté par un tel talent
d'écriture un tel talent de jeu aussi
la série est une habile réflexions sont
des rapports de pouvoir dans un monde de
courtisans ou les alliances se font et
se défont où tout le monde rêve d'être
calife à la place du calife ils sont
méchants ils sont mais ce qu'est ils
sont impitoyables ils sont prêts à
s'entretuer toute la famille c'est toute
une famille d'un clan et je trouve que
c'est très shakespearien
succession c'est la misère des riches
mais c'est aussi une satire du
capitalisme sauvage dans ce qu'il a de
plus monstrueux je pense que ce qui veut
démontrer c'est à quel point la richesse
et le pouvoir déshumanise les gens ils
se rendent plus compte de rien ils se
rendent plus compte de leurs privilèges
ils se rendent plus compte des gens qui
souffrent au tour et c'est seul sait la
déshumanisation de ces gens là c'est pas
juste la misère des riches ça va plus
loin que sept mois l'air de choquer même
fois primé la série succession reçu un
accueil dithyrambique succession pour
moi c'est une des meilleures séries du
début du xxième siècle mais surtout je
pense qu'en termes de construction
dramatique c'est une des meilleures
choses que j'ai vues même au cinéma
depuis très très longtemps et un travail
d'écriture phénoménal
la saison 3 reprend exactement où la
précédente nous avait laissés cannes
dont le trahit son père il a guère sera
impitoyable
succession à découvrir sur la plateforme
créée ici n'est bien alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal